[Musica]
[Applauso]
fan ghiaccia che sono qualche brutta
stagione boyle
per chi fosse interessato è
sostanzialmente una statua di direzione
nelle chiese gotiche per spaventare
satana avuto festa del pd di pompei e
qui non capisco se sono l'avvocato del
partito democratico
oppure l'avvocata del partito del sesso
orale
se dovete rimetterti l'arcobaleno brava
credo che lo sai qui siamo proprio al
turismo si faccia una domanda e si dia
una risposta ma vai a fare la combinata
grossa e senza dignità
eccetera eccetera eccetera questo è solo
un assaggio e più garbato e docente di
ciò che da anni
ricevo praticamente tutti i giorni su
tutte le mete forme social altro
facebook e trova questa roba qui apro
messanger e trovo questa roba qui leggo
i commenti uguale twitter leader ed è
sempre un buon giornalismo
ovviamente ora trovare vederci suu kyi
scherzo ma vi posso assicurare che dover
convivere con questa marea di euro
quotidiano è devastante
anzi è devastante per me che sono un
avvocato che ho della vivibilità che ho
delle spalle larghe che so reagirà che
si deve fare causa non devo nemmeno
pagare l'avvocato pensate come possa
essere per ogni altra vittima lo so
l'odio il bullismo non sono una novità
sono sempre esistiti ma avevano bisogno
di una caratteristica per manifestarsi
il faccia a faccia
mi ricordo quando alla fine degli anni
novanta siravo primi i primi pride me lo
gridano in faccia lesbica di merda
ricordo a scuola nel mio piccolo paese
in provincia di trapani
trovero gridavano in faccia che sembrava
un maschio ci mettevano la faccia il
nome l'identità e mi guardavano negli
occhi e monari insulto si consumava
trame lui lei e pochi testimoni
oggi no oggi la persona che ho di in
luce rai più davanti non devi più
guardando negli occhi
oggi l'olio corre velocemente online è
facile immediato non richiede coraggio
del persino monimo e avviene davanti a
centinaia di persone quando va bene a
decine di migliaia fra la maggior parte
delle volte per cui sentirsi dire brutta
accesso essere colpiti nella propria
anima nella propria immagine non è più
una questione tra te e chi ti odia no
avviene tutto davanti a decine di
migliaia di persone di altre persone che
guardano stanno silenzioso ma nel
frattempo ti giudicano e si è devastante
in questi anni si sono moltiplicati sia
in europa che in america negli stati
uniti i suicidi di giovani e
giovanissimi a causa di varie forme di
vittime di oggi di forme di odio online
e di violenza colori in tanti rinunciano
al proprio diritto ad avere un'esistenza
sui social si chiama social death note
online negli ultimi anni anche in italia
questo fenomeno è spaventosamente
esploso il nostro e la violenza da
eccezione sono diventate le forme le
nuove forme del confronto se non ho
degli altri qualcuno o di rotta e
correndo agito davanti all'esplodere del
fenomeno
comunque tanto pericoloso la politica e
media le istituzioni fine anno si morte
come se nulla stesse accadendo ed è ha
colpito che mi sono chiesta ok io cosa
posso fare senza attendere i tempi dei
gestori delle casseforme della politica
stessa
la prima idea che probabilmente a
qualcuno verrà è come vittima poi
querelare eppure la corona davanti a un
fenomeno tanto mostruoso come questo
talvolta non basta una querela
molto spesso per un odiatore è una
medaglia guadagnata sul campo alla fine
alla punizione si arriva con l'arrivo
dopo anni è una sentenza qualche mese di
carcere che mai si sconterà e allora ho
pensato no serve qualcos'altro
serve colpire loden 3 tanto velocemente
e serve fare ancora più male nel senso
ovviamente metaforico del termine ovvero
serve colpire al portafogli dove proprio
fa più male
e cosa si può farlo con azioni civili
uno pensa ma i processi civili durano
anni è risaputo quando mai si terrà
giustizia e di quel che sta il punto di
forza di una grande idea di cambiamento
perché si va un giudizio perché si
sostiene un giudizio normalmente perché
si crede di uscirne vittoriosi
ma nel nostro caso la per stordire
citata in giudizio macchiata di commenti
che sono incontrovertibili il cui porto
è incontrovertibile e dunque sono bene
di avere poche speranze di vincere
perché appunto insulto e visibile e
chiaro e quindi l'odiato re volodja
trici ha più scelte pagare
subito oppure affrontare un processo che
gli costerà il doppio il triplo che
riporterà via anni e che probabilmente
perderà di sicuro
alla fine sapete cosa succederà chi
pagherà
e non lo farà più né lo faranno tutti
quelli che verranno a sapere che questa
persona ha pagato e da qui che nasce o
di arechi costa quando nel giugno del
2019 io e maura gancitano con fondatrice
di odiarsi costa abbiamo lanciato questa
campagna lo abbiamo fatto con una
diretta improvvisata su facebook mentre
eravamo in campania lo ricordo benissimo
a immaginare come avremmo potuto
cambiare il social ormai diventati come
spesso ma ora dice un giardino di casa
veramente sforzo quella diretta in pochi
giorni diventa un caso nazionale
ne parlano tutti sembrava che una grande
parata del mondo social
soprattutto di chi subisce odio online
quasi in maniera costi quotidiana non
aspettasse altro con aria reti posta
oggi aiutiamo persone vittime di ex pci
di reati d'odio a capire per esempio la
distinzione tra un insulto e libertà di
espressione
lo facciamo anche in un'ottica
preventiva perché a loro volta non
commettano gli stessi errori di un altro
odiatore ma sapete qual è il dato più
interessante di tutto ciò le scuse sono
lettere di scuse gli odiatori che il
pubblico ti insultano ma che poi in chat
al telefono il privato sul making
piangono si scusano si mettono
letteralmente in ginocchio si pentono e
no
vi assicuro che non c'è alcuna
soddisfazione in molte opzioni perché
fondo davanti a una richiesta di un
risarcimento l'odiato restà di dover
pagare cominciò a dire no nero imei non
sono così io non sono questa persona io
non ero così non so cosa mi sia preso
mia madre sta male
mio marito sta male non ho i soldi non
un lavoro sono disoccupata e dunque
capisci che in qualche modo anche loro
sono delle vittime vittime di chi per
esempio quell'odio lo alimenta e fa
credere che sia normale e parti di
farcire da qualcuno perché ferito
nell'animo nell'immagine non è come
pontifica qualche giornalista qualche
filosofo una limitazione della libertà
di pensiero di opinione perché insulto
non è una libertà la risoluzione non è
una libertà o diario di costa non limita
le libertà
io non limita le libertà non ho nessun
potere per farlo e lo giuro può dire di
costa tutela i diritti in generale
stiamo cercando di tutelare i diritti
vedete oggi avrei potuto raccontarvi
della mia paura personale del
cambiamento quella che per esempio mi ha
preso quando ha 18 anni e baciato per la
prima volta una donna di una persona del
mio stesso sesso
gli ho detto a adesso ho capito come
dovrebbe essere ma allo stesso tempo
pensato non avrò mai una vita normale
potrei parlarvi della paura di lasciare
la propria terra per migrare dove si
pensa di avere una possibilità invece
deciso di parlarvi della paura di
iniziare qualcosa
un'azione collettiva
e voleva e vuole fare una cosa
gigantesca battersi perché le web sia un
posto migliore perché quando iniziato
questa battaglia
i loro treni confortanti invece che
diminuire si è moltiplicato a dismisura
e ha colpito persino le persone che amo
di più perché una battaglia contro
lawyer ed in rete e skoda per tutti
soprattutto per quelli che vogliono
continuare a tenere la rete con una
discarica
vedete la verna contro lodi online è una
nuova frontiera per il diritto e il
diritto a vivere la nostra esistenza
social senza il timore di violenze
insulti minacce perché il diritto e come
un giano bifronte a due facce una
statica che tutela lo status quo e una
dinamica che diviene che può divenire
io personalmente maneggio quest'ultima
faccia del diritto perché io con sieme
ad altri si possa modellare dei diritti
nuovi filippi che il più delle volte
oggi hanno nemmeno un nome diritti che
il più delle volte oggi dobbiamo
immaginare il lato selvaggio quello meno
battuto è però fermati bisogna rivedere
alcune categorie tradizionali bisognava
interpretarle e bisogna aggiornabile ed
è chiaro che questo fa paura a cui
invece si senta ampiamente confortevole
medici ampiamente già dispone di un
implicito timore nella maggioranza che
il riconoscimento di nuovo diritto possa
ledere il proprio status quo che in
concessione
si traduca in una minaccia del proprio
di reggio
mi piacerebbe discutere a lungo anche
della parola concessione e diritti non
si concedono non è per concessione di
qualcuno o almeno non lo è da molti anni
per sfortuna presunto riconoscere le
unioni civili non significa pregiudicare
il matrimonio tradizionale riconoscere
l'olio di soia che è nato in italia non
significa pregiudicare il nostro diritto
di cittadinanza
oggi il mio obiettivo è esattamente
questo diffondere una cultura che io
chiamo e dei diritti xxl così comodi e
confortevoli da starci dentro tutti ma
davvero tutti conoscete la legge di la
notte è cominciata già dal peso che
mezzo secolo prima della nascita di
cristo e la musica applicata alla
clinica in natura nulla si crea nulla si
distrugge tutto si trasforma
significa che non puoi creare qualcosa
di nuovo
senza togliere a qualcosa di vecchio
prende il suo come sempre del fuoco per
crearsi c'è bisogno che qualcosa brucia
e cioè in qualche nuovo si distrugge e
si trasformi il fuoco
questo principio vale per tutto e natura
entrambe prima cosa i diritti i diritti
sfuggono a questa legge universale
i diritti sono l'unica cosa al mondo che
si può creare senza che a nessuno venga
tolto alcunché se io posso sposare una
persona dello stesso sesso
lo stop di ennio nulla a chi sceglie di
sposare persone del sesso opposto
e io scelgo di rimozione non sotto gli
anni ma chi sceglie di non farlo i tempi
per concludere le terminiamo questo
principio nel diritto nulla si crea
nulla si distrugge tutto si deve
trasformare la